madame monsieur bonsoir le bilan
s'aggrave à nîmes 11 morts 45 mille
sinistrés
le président de la république s'est
rendu sur les lieux les négociations
salariales dans la fonction publique
sont mal partis les syndicats exigent un
rattrapage immédiat sur les salaires de
88 le gouvernement renaat drôle
d'endroit pour une rencontre c'est le
titre du dernier film du couple phare du
cinéma français deneuve depardieu
invités de ce journal nîmes aujourd'hui
s'est appliqué à revivre tant bien que
mal dans la boue des tonnes de boue
charriés par les inondations qui ont
véritablement ravagé la ville
onze personnes ont été retrouvées mortes
jusqu'ici et les recherches continuent
dans les décombres le quartier nord a
été le plus touché c'est là que rémy
roche et jean corneille ont passé la
journée
regardez le cauchemar nous sommes au
nord de nîmes quartiers populaires
ouvriers pratiquement que des
habitations modestes souvent occupés par
des personnes âgées
seul un drame en une heure une heure
hier matin pour que ces petites rues
étroites soient transformées en torrents
de boue pourront infernal projetant les
voitures les unes contre les autres les
unes sur les autres
aux intersections le monde s'engouffre
et ravagent tout les rez de chaussée
dont les occupants ont tout perdu je
suis arrivé c'était 8h à 9h30 on était
déjà à ce niveau là
je suis rien à manger j'ai laissé ma
voiture un peu plus haut j'ai fini les
cinquante mètres une croche
c'est pourquoi durant ce pour quoi faire
trembler de peur le moindre bruit la
nuit où ma part que ça s'écroule sans
compter les pillages ont pris
que faire en contresens pas de quoi mais
bon moi
tout mon lit est passé par l'athlète mon
manager curiae un peu rien de rien plus
rien j'ai pu de neige j'ai plus rien
pris a pris ne peut rien dire dans le
quartier qui sont les gens sont hébétés
iria j'ai été faire un tour les jambes
femme qui pleure qui ont tout perdu
après la pâle chagoua mecs matin je
passais les petits grands mères qui
appelait au secours venez les ds ou non
labour sur les affaires boissons prime
d'engagement mais elles ont terni tout
perdu tout abus on sait tout
et puis que le plan orsec a été
déclenché hier matin des moyens
considérables sont à l'oeuvre pour
rétablir les services vitaux de la ville
600 pompiers 120 gendarmes 200 employés
de les df 400 cheminots 120 experts des
télécommunications et 200 employés de la
direction départementale de l'équipement
sont à l'oeuvre ou en étant ce soir
dominique verdeilhan le canal des
jardins de la fontaine transformé en
cimetière de voitures toute la journée à
l'aide d'immenses grues les pompiers ont
repêché dans une eau boueuse des
dizaines de véhicules à tout moment les
sauveteurs craignent et de découvrir
dans cet amas de tôles de nouvelles
victimes dans les bassins ce ne sont qu
à mon serment de gravats détritus
branche ou affaire personnelle sonné et
bt incrédule après une nuit
cauchemardesque
les nîmois ont réalisé l'ampleur de la
catastrophe en découvrant ce matin le
nouveau visage de leur rue chaussée
défoncée canalisations éventrées
voitures enchevêtrées
les trottoirs ont explosé sous la
pression de l'eau infiltrée
l'électricité a été rétablie ce soir
mais le téléphone est encore coupée
interdiction aux nîmois de boire l'eau
courante qui n'est peut-être pas potable
la rapidité a surpris tout le monde est
souvent qu'est qui pouvait pas aller
plus loin qui ont mis le shell sur les
voitures jusque chez nous et voilà tout
le monde est venu chez nous on l'était
vingtaine dans la maison
tout ce ce qui se situe au rez de
chaussée a été touché à l'hôpital la
salle d'urgence des hordes usage le
scanner a été emportée par les eaux plus
de cinquante mille personnes sont
sinistrées et c'est toute une ville qui
est à reconstruire
oui les lignes de chemin de fer et les
routes sont rouvertes l'électricité est
à peu près rétabli mais 20% seulement
des lignes téléphoniques ont peut être
réparé jusqu'ici ce qui explique la
difficulté que vous avez eu peut-être si
vous avez essayé de joindre des gens à
nîmes le président de la république
s'est rendu cet après midi dans la ville
sinistrée
accompagné du maire et des autorités du
département
il a vu de près les dégâts michel
mompontet françois mitterrand dans la
cité gardoise et les nîmois qui
l'interpellent monsieur le président
monsieur le président venez chez nous
venez vous rendre compte par vous même
de l'étendue des dégâts de ce qui nous
reste
cette femme ne voudra pas lâcher la main
du président avant que celui ci ne les
accompagner chez elle un domicile
dévastés comme tant d'autres par l'ebu
meurtrière d'hier en compagnie de jean
bousquet le maire de nîmes et de pierre
joxe françois mitterrand arrivé dans la
capitale gardoise peu avant 17 heures a
eu le temps de s'entretenir avec ces
nîmois ce soir traumatisé désemparé
criant à l'aide
pont de quart de nos place carrée route
d'uzès françois mitterrand s'est rendu à
pied dans la foule sur tous les points
noirs de la cité gardoise
tout sera mis en oeuvre a affirmé le
président de la république pour aider
nîmes et sa région
pc de secours l'hommage enfin à ceux qui
sont battus depuis hier matin contre le
déluge
déjà qualifiée d'historique je vous
rappelle le dernier bilan donc onze
morts 45 mille sinistrés et des dégâts
matériels évalués à plus de 4 milliards
de francs
monsieur bousquet bonsoir vous avez
déclaré votre ville en état de
catastrophe nationale déjà de façon à
bénéficier des aides de l'état et aussi
des assurances ampleur on peut
s'imaginer qu'il faut mieux au minimum
l'aide de l'état et violente celle
suffira il faudra peut être aller à
l'europe
mais aujourd'hui nîmes c'est une grande
cité quinze mille hectares alors d'abord
d'abord no more et puis ensuite
l'étendue cette vague qui est tombée sur
la ville qui sur 10 km et qui a tout
balayé dans tous les quartiers
aujourd'hui donc toutes les usines
détruites nous avons quatre mille
personnes minimum qui sont en chômage
technique dont le le drame c'est une
très grande ampleur il fera que la
solidarité soit grande
alors vous allez présider je crois dans
quelques minutes un conseil municipal
exceptionnel mais quelles priorités
peut-on assignés devant l'ampleur des
dégâts justement d'abord d'abord essayé
d'alimenter en eau en électricité et
puis les logements on a visité les
quartiers où les gens ont de la boue
dans dans les appartements il faut que
dès demain matin tout le monde soit sur
sur le champ pour essayer d'apporter
rapidement rapidement une amélioration
car c'est souvent insoutenables pour
beaucoup alors dès la première
évaluation mieux sur bousquet bien sûr
la polémique
on vous accuse d'avoir plutôt consacré
d'argent des dépenses somptuaires au
culturel plutôt que d'avoir moderniser
l'infrastructure de la ville votre
réponse
c'est quand même un peu léger et une
polémique qui n'a pas sa place je pense
dans le drame d'aujourd'hui alors
j'attendrai sur les communications
scientifiques pour répondre mais je peux
vous assurer que après ce qui s'est
passé qui est totalement historique que
ce qui est arrivé à nîmes aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas parler de des d'erreur de
d'urbanisme je crois que c'est un peu
léger comme mais surtout c'est très
déplacé
quand vous parlez de d'expertisé
scientifique vous voulez dire quoi et
bien que les experts vont nous donner
toutes les précipitations et les raisons
de ce désastre car sûrement ce sont des
précipitations tout à fait exceptionnel
on parle de 230 mm d'eau en trois heures
alors voilà je crois qu'on doit
réfléchir sur ces chiffres
alors une question qui intéresse tout le
monde est d'abord bien sûr les nîmois
monsieur bousquet c'est qui va payer
c'est la question vous intéressent elles
concernent encore une fois tous les
habitants nîmes qu'elle est il si nous
avions une réunion il ya cinq minutes
avec le président le conseil général je
le président du conseil régional jacques
blanc monsieur le préfet donc le
président de la république et elle a
tout à l'heure demain il ya conseil des
ministres je pense que demain matin on
aura la participation de chacun et on va
regarder si ça suffit mais il faut
partir sur des chiffres alors justement
je vous propose de voir déjà et de
rester avec nous si vous voulez bien
pourvoir à peu près qu'elles sont la
nature et le montant des indemnisations
auxquelles ont droit les particuliers
aussi les services de la ville
christophe martet
400 millions de francs emporté par les
flots ce serait la facture des
inondations pour les seuls particuliers
dès parution au journal officiel de
l'arrêté reconnaissant l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
toutes les personnes sinistrées ont dix
jours pour faire une déclaration à leur
assureur
c'est la première étape indispensable
pour être indemnisé par la suite elles
devront établir une estimation des biens
perdus ou endommagés
l'assureur dispose d'un délai de trois
mois à partir de la publication au
journal officiel de l'arrêté pour
indemniser ses clients
sauf cas de force majeure par exemple il
est bien évident que la suite d'une
inondation
les experts ne peuvent effectuer leur
travail correctement tant que tous les
biens endommagés et ne sont pas sec
quant aux dommages subis par les
équipements publics la note sera lourde
on parle déjà de quatre milliards et
demi de francs
trop lourde en tout cas pour les seules
collectivités locales l'état devrait
déclarer nîmes zones sinistrées ce qui
permettrait alors de débloquer les fonds
nécessaires
monsieur jusqu'à une dernière question
parmi les urgences dans vous allez
décider ce soir en conseil municipal
peut-être conseils juridiques aux nîmois
pour savoir comment ils peuvent depuis
ce matin dans les jambes
en mairie on accueille avec les
assureurs de la ville qui en donnait
déjà les premiers conseils et un
communiqué qui sort demain où on peut
entreprendre tous travaux sans avoir à
tendre le passage de n'espère non dès
demain on peut se mettre se mettre en
action les assurances nous garantissent
la protection c'est déjà un avantage
fantastique parce qu'on peut commencer à
travailler maintenant nous disions bons
les chiffres sont là qui va payer
il faudra une très grande solidaire
solidarité tout à l'heure le conseil
général de l'hérault nous a fait savoir
qu'il nous aiderait financièrement
il ya des villes comme la ville de paris
qui nous a aussi proposé des aides
monsieur chirac nous a proposé son aide
donc les aides arrivent la ville de
montpellier nous aide voilà je pense
qu'il faut une solidarité à tous les
niveaux et je suis persuadé que nous y
arriverons monsieur bousquet merci et
bon courage alors justement quelques
informations pratiques pour que la
solidarité puissent parvenir
aning d'abord en ce qui concerne le
téléphone vous le savez n'est pas
complètement rétabli mais des lignes
prioritaires ont été installés notamment
à la préfecture vous pouvez donc appelé
le 66 23 00 51 ou le 66 23 00 54
différents organismes s'emploie déjà
dépêché sur place des secours en vivre
en vêtements et en argent pour les plus
démunis
vous allez lire leurs coordonnées il
s'agit de la croix rouge française ccp
donc 600 00 il y paris le secours
populaire français ccp 23 33 s paris et
le secours catholique
voici ccp 737
g et j'ajoute que jeudi soir à 22h
claude sérillon présentera une édition
spéciale en direct de nîmes il en
appellera notamment à la solidarité des
différentes villes françaises il y a
près d'un mois ont retrouvé carbonisé
dans l'eure le corps de la petite
delphine qui avait disparu d'un camp de
scouts villerville dans le calvados et
bien le directeur de ce camp l'aumônier
et trois moniteurs sont en garde à vue
depuis ce matin agnès poirier
après un mois d'enquêté peut être une
piste
depuis ce matin le directeur l'omonia
les trois moniteurs du camp scout sont
en garde à vue
officiellement il s'agit de vérifier les
emplois du temps en fait les analyses
des affaires de delphine des cheveux
retrouvés dans la voiture du directeur
du camp ont ré ces derniers jours fait
avancer l'enquêté
depuis un mois tout avait pourtant été
tenté quand delphine disparaître en
pleine nuit du camp scout ses parents ne
veulent pas croire à une fugue
les recherches commencent des milliers
d' affiches sont placardées plusieurs
centaines de militaires de gendarmes de
pompiers kadri la région fouilles
chaque bosquet chaque étang en désespoir
de cause le père de delphine sillonne
les routes en appelant son fumer tue
quelques jours après l'arrêt des
recherches on retrouve un corps calciné
dans la forêt à quelques kilomètres du
camp le top s'il confirme il s'agit bien
d'eux
le fils ce soir cinq personnes sont en
garde à vue pour les nécessités de
l'enquète affirmé les gendarmes accord à
l'assemblée nationale où les députés ont
commencé aujourd'hui à examiner le
projet de loi créant un revenu minimum
d'insertion pour les plus pauvres accord
de principe des différents groupes pour
voter le projet mais divergences surtout
dans les rangs socialistes sur ses
modalités
pascal guimier une fois n'est pas
coutume tout le monde ici a l'air plutôt
d'accord revenu minimum d'insertion le
pc votre à pour le rpr aussi l'udf
idem quant aux centristes ils ne
voteront pas content si le président
d'un conseil général qui expérimente le
revenu minimum depuis quatre ans
jeune fille est peu favorable pour
revenu minimum d'insertion
m
on est allés voter malgré les réserves
du nizan sur l'abandon jeu
les actions d'insertion nous avons
toujours mené la lutte contre la
pauvreté pour aider les plus démunis
donc nous considérons que ce projet est
en quelque sorte le résultat nos actions
alors alors le gouvernement pourrait
être le plus heureux du monde si si les
socialistes voulaient bien suivre comme
un seul homme mais pour les députés du
ps le rmi est avant tout un droit un
droit qui doit être ouvert au plus grand
nombre
amendement à l'appui le groupe demande
donc des conditions d'attribution moins
rigoureuse à la clé un risque celui de
faire passer leurs vues avant
l'insertion de faire de l'assistance
sociale sans formation professionnelle
ce principe il ne peut se réduire au
seul droit à l'allocation si commode que
cela puisse paraître on le voit députés
et gouvernement ne parle pas tout à fait
le même langage ce soir en ce moment
même claude evin est en train de
s'expliquer devant les députés
socialistes en petit comité
on dit même que michel rocard se serait
déplacé en fait en cette rentrée
parlementaire tout se passe comme si le
parti voulait démontrer qu'il est bien
le fer de lance de la solidarité
quitte à faire pression sur son
gouvernement et bien c'est confirmé le
premier ministre michel rocard participe
lui même ce soir à la réunion du groupe
socialiste pour trouver un compromis
avec les députés
le problème essentiel mais il y en a
beaucoup est en effet de décider si
l'insertion est prioritaire c'est à dire
si l'attribution d'un revenu minimum est
lié à un effort social ou professionnel
de la part de l'individu qui a droit
or on a du mal à cerner le nombre les
besoins et les capacités réelles
d'insertion de tous ceux qui peuvent
avoir droit ce revenu minimum
il s'agit vous le savez d'une allocation
mensuelle de 2000 francs pour une
personne seule
trois mille francs pour un couple plus
600 francs par enfant à charge
certains cas sont évidents comme celui
de cette jeune femme qu'à rencontrer eve
mettait longtemps que la casserole et
sur le réchaud
ici le gaz est coupé depuis dix mois
l'électricité depuis trois mois
la galère commence en 1985 pour muriel
guernalec licenciés économiques
elle navigue pendant trois ans entre
petits boulots et chômage et puis en
juillet c'est la tuile
alors qu'elle travaille depuis cinq
semaines en intérim comme
manutentionnaire elle se casse un genou
accidents du travail certes mais comme
elle n'a pas cotisé trois mois d'affilée
elle n'a pas droit à des indemnités
journalières
elle est en rééducation pour plusieurs
semaines va encore sans aucune ressource
maintenant j'ai peur et je ne lâche plus
rien juste les chip cotisé pendant
quelques temps et le chevalier les a
cédés par le chômage et puis le mais
c'est côté social mais pas pour moi par
le coup parce que moi je le vois rien
bah oui ça ça je veux pas le caue je me
nourris ce qu'est ce que je te fais rien
donc je peux pas je peux pas les acheter
à manger je vais rien vous c'est sûr bon
sens moi j'ai des amis qui sont là qui
me l'a mangé mais les amis c'est anti
mais ça va durer des mois et des mois
mais moins de problèmes s'il veut encore
pas trop manger ça ne dérange pas mon
problème c'est de payer mon loyer la fin
du mois et pas me retrouver devant je
sais c'est un problème c'est déjà pas me
retrouver dans la rue cp est resté comme
vous les gp stressé j'ai plus rien bon
ben il sans électricité on peut encore y
arriver mais sans maison et sans toit
pour dormir moi je peux pas y arriver on
pour un toit donc il faut supprimer
région vous voyez plus mon retard de
loyer
il faut cinq enfants en place du rayon
court
ces vols j'ai pleuré
déjà j'ai peur
l'université de lille est en crise
hier nous vous montrions le curieux
procédé choisi pour sélectionner les
élèves de l'unité de mathématiques trop
nombreux par rapport aux moyens
disponibles le tirage au sort via le
ministre d'éducation nationale lionel
jospin a condamné aujourd'hui cette
méthode il s'est engagé à faire un
effort particulier pour cet acabit et a
plaidé me mais seulement dans le cadre
du budget 89
la toile de fond est sombre grogne chez
les infirmières chez les postiers et les
gardiens de prison dont le mouvement de
revendication durci la marge de
manoeuvre est étroite
le ministre de la fonction publique
michel durafour ouvert aujourd'hui avec
les syndicats les négociations
salariales pour la période 88 89 en
annonçant d'entrée qu'il n'y aurait pas
de nouvelle augmentation générale avant
la fin de l'année gérard leclerc pour
les syndicats le compte n'est pas bon
entre les prix qui progressent cette
année au rythme de près de 3% et les
salaires augmentent et seulement 2 2%
quant aux prévisions pour 1989 elles
sont jugées hasardeuse
les fonctionnaires l'ont d'autant plus
mauvaise qu'ils ont accumulées ces
dernières années des pertes de pouvoir
d'achat jusqu'à 10% depuis 1981 si l'on
en croit la cgt les mouvements de grève
observée dans l'audiovisuel comme chez
les infirmières ou les gardiens de
prisons seraient les premiers signes
d'une véritable exaspération
bien entendu le ministère ne fait pas
les mêmes calculs avec l'ancienneté et
les promotions
le pouvoir d'achat serait maintenu
surtout le gouvernement assure ne pas
avoir le choix
le déficit catastrophique de 9 milliards
du commerce extérieur le mois dernier
est un coup de semonce
les français consomment trop à terme
cela pourrait mettre en péril la monnaie
et le redressement économique alors que
les fonctionnaires pensait pouvoir
goûter enfin à l'amélioration générale
on le ressort la rigueur difficile à
avaler et tous les syndicats sauf la cgt
demande ce soir que la prochaine
discussion ait lieu dans les quinze
jours avec un coup de pouce sur les
salaires de 88 folle de quoi il en
appellerait à la grève
satisfaction en revanche du côté des
contrôleurs aériens après trois mois de
négociations discrètes michel delbarre
le ministre des transports a signé avec
les principaux syndicats de la
navigation aérienne
un accord de trois ans qui met fin à
l'interminable conflit de l'été les
contrôleurs obtiennent l'essentiel de
leurs revendications salariales sauf
l'intégration des primes dans le montant
de la retraite
5h05 heures pour reconstituer les
circonstances exactes d'un meurtre de
quelques minutes 22 mois après la mort
de malik oussékine cet étudiant tué au
quartier latin redescendre 86 le juge
d'instruction a réuni la nuit dernière
les protagonistes de la faire emmanuel
vanier face à face pour la première fois
paul b selon le principal témoin et les
deux policiers inculpés casque cagoule
c'est la tenue qu'il portait dans la
nuit du 5 au 6 décembre 86 christophe
garcia 25 ans lui seul reconnaît avoir
frappé malik oussékine dans le hall du
20 rue monsieur le prince
tout l'enjeu de cette reconstitution
était donc de préciser le rôle du
deuxième inculpé le brigadier chenilles
qui nie avoir pénétré dans le hall de
l'immeuble
pourtant larmes du brigadier avait été
retrouvé dans le hall mais il prétend
toujours l'avoir perdue dans la rue
version contredite par le témoignage de
paul bezes long les deux parties sont
restées sur leur position
le mystère de cette arme reste donc le
point clef du dossier dont l'instruction
devrait bientôt être close
6 en dix jours près de 21 mois de
détention ce soir mais thil échoir singh
est libre ce ressortissant indien qui
tue l'air d'une carte de résident
permanent aux états unis a été libéré
hier soir par le djihad islamique pour
la libération de la palestine qui
détient encore trois américains dès le
mois de septembre l'organisation
clandestine avait laissé entendre
qu'elle était prête à faire un geste
dans le cadre de la descente enregistré
au proche orient il reste 14 otages
étrangers au liban dont neuf américains
un dictateur organise-t-il un référendum
pour le perdre
c'est la question que se posent les
chiliens à la veille du premier scrutin
démocratique qui doit avoir lieu dans le
pays depuis plus de 15 ans les sondages
sont défavorables au général pinochet
paradoxalement ces sondages nourrissent
l'inquiétude de l'opinion sur des
lendemains qui déchantent ray pour le
moment c'est l'effervescence la parole
retrouvée les cris et les rumeurs comme
l'a constaté ces jours ci bernard
benyamin pays étrange que ce chili
d'octobre 1988
elie étrange où un régime militaire
toujours aussi fort en apparence s'est
engagé lui même dans un processus qui
pourrait bien lui être fatale le général
président candidat à sa propre
succession bat la campagne mais le coeur
n'y est plus vraiment les dernières
manifestations en sa faveur
l'on paraît-il beaucoup déçu mais pour
s'exprimer
il n'y a pas que la parole il y a aussi
les murs qui se couvre de moules à alès
ses fresques réalisées par des étudiants
regroupés en brigade ainsi de jour en
jour
santiago se transforme santiago se
colore pour mieux marquer le changement
politique qui semble s'annoncer certes a
annoncé aux gens ce qui se passe et font
partie de la lutte politique
par exemple ici on se demande comment
créer sous une dictature
la réponse c'est de créer avec amour
et puis il est la télévision avec ses
records d'audience battu pour les
émissions de la campagne électorale en
15 minutes chaque soir pendant un mois
le programme du nom a fait littéralement
exploser le discours traditionnel du
pouvoir avec cette séquence par exemple
une vieille femme qui entre dans une
épicerie et pour faire ses courses comme
on enseigne olivier passot penser à la
main elle a besoin de tes et l'épicier
lui demande si elle veut en acheter un
ou deux sachets on est maman
pays étrange je vous le disais tout à
l'heure où l'opposition encore du mal à
imaginer qu'elle peut gagner mercredi le
jour du plébiscite
car c'est vrai qu'on ne se débarrasse
pas si facilement des réflexes de peur
acquis durant quinze ans de régimes
militaires particulièrement au moment du
vote
c'est vrai aussi que les risques de
fraude sont toujours possibles mais
enfin si l'on s'en tient au dernier
sondage c'est le nom qui devrait
l'emporter dans tout le chili pour ces
premières élections libres depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'un certain à
augusto pinochet le pdi site aura donc
lieu demain en présence de quelques 300
observateurs envoyés par les parlements
d'une trentaine de pays
grave accident de train la nuit dernière
en union soviétique à se faire de l'orse
dans l'oural quatre morts 280 blessés
dans une explosion due à la collision de
wagon plein d'explosifs
vous avez apporté à la france une
véritable joie c'était beau et d'une
façon générale c'est est réussie c'est
en ces termes que le président
mitterrand a félicité tout à l'heure les
acteurs français qui avait enlevé leur
canotier
il était rentré de séoul ce matin
rentrée avec beaucoup de retard pour
cause de brouillard
drôle d'endroit pour une rencontre
il ne s'agit pas de studio de télévision
mais d'un parking c'est là que vous vous
rencontrer catherine deneuve gérard
depardieu dans ce film qui sort demain
et qui est signée par françois dupeyron
un film dont vous êtes heureux
l'un et l'autre oui oui globalement très
heureux en ce qui me concerne et je ne
dirait pas le contraire non plus alors
on est presque déjà dans vos dans la
lenteur de vos réponses dans l'ambiance
de ce film en film le très étrange et je
vous propose d'en voir un extrait un
parking au bord de l'autoroute une femme
que l'on jette un homme qui bien sûr
c'est le début du film n'en veut pas
bassam pourtant
dans la poule longtemps j'ai pas rendu
là une femme se confirme dans la poule
la poule de luxe
alors c'est un film étrange parce qu'on
dirait presque du théâtre unité de lieu
unité d'action unité de temps c'est ça
qu'il voulait attirer l'un et l'autre
dans ce scénario
gérard louise moi ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est de voix que d'abord c'est de voir
un drôle de couple
enfin un rôle de femme et puis par la
même occasion un couple dernière c'est
vrai que le théâtre si j'aime j'adore le
théâtre et puis je trouvais que c'était
difficile de rendre une autoroute de
essayé de parler de l'intimité sur des
gens qui parce qu'ils traversent
moi c'est ce qui aurait pu m'arrêter
parce que j'ai jamais fait de théâtre et
c'est quelque chose que je redoute
beaucoup mais en même temps je reconnais
que quand j'ai lu le scénario c'est ce
qui m'a beaucoup fasciné par l'histoire
c'était c'est deux personnages épinglé
la nuit cet homme qui allait repousser
cette femme longtemps d'abord parce
qu'une femme qui s'est jetée comme ça
dans un an quand on est seul on a décidé
de s'attaquer à une chose concrète qui
est le moteur sa voiture c'est ça fait
désordre et puis ça fait empêche de
travailler c'est vrai et c'est un va
être très résistant d'ailleurs la presse
dans cette femme mais ce qui me plaisait
surtout c'était je crois à l'idée de
m'affronter avec avec gérard dans la
même direction c'est à dire de s'engager
dans quelque chose je savais que
j'aurais besoin de lui je savais que
j'aurais pu que je pourrai l'aider qu'on
allait avoir un vrai tête à tête parce
que gerra j'ai tourné plusieurs fois
avec lui on a eu des très belles scènes
mais on n'a jamais tourné aussi
longuement ensemble
alors justement on sent dans ce film une
extraordinaire complicité entre vous qui
est presque plus une complicité je
dirais de deux coffres de stature plus
que de tempérament alors c'est vrai
c'est votre cinquième film ensemble
c'est parce que vous ne connaissez bien
ou pas ce que vous
mérité l'autre d'une certaine manière
méritée mais je sais que j'avais assez
complémentaires même physiquement je
dire physiologiquement comme ça je
trouve que quand on nous voit ensemble à
l'écran il ya quelque chose de
complémentaire
non pas qu'il soit fort et que moi je
sois fragile mais gérard à la grèce
n'avait plus fort et plus oui c'est plus
souterrain de femmes et disons que a
priori à l'avant-première premières
impressions oui et après moi j'ai des
brutalités ou des brusqueries comme ça
que j'ai rien n'a pas géré à une voie
beaucoup plus douce avec des inflexions
beaucoup plus que moi
moi je peux être même sèche parfois et
je trouve que ça fait une musique un peu
différente
à l'arrivée un vrai couple comme ça sur
au cinéma ou même dans la vie des gens
dans la viseur tout le règne au cinéma
alors justement cinq films déjà ensemble
et vous êtes vous est consacré le couple
mythique du cinéma français donc ça veut
dire que pour notre plus grand bonheur à
tous vous allez continuer longtemps et
plusieurs fois ça ce sera la réalité du
jugement final qu'il décidera mais après
c'est vrai que c'est très agréable de se
retrouver sur un sur un film comme celui
là avec des rouleaux s'y déroulent aussi
fort et au fil du tournage de nuit c'est
très particulier comment bien vivre
actuellement femmes avec lesquelles on a
envie de partager quelque chose au
cinéma c'est vrai et le couple mythique
vous vous trouvez bien assortis moi je
vois que le groupe utiliserait ne pas
parler ne pas se montrer ne pas venir la
télévision fallait qu'il parte sur les
écrans et puis ne plus ne plus
apparaître les couples mythiques surface
des choses qui devraient bien longtemps
après sa mort l'idée de a priori de
faire rêver sur une image du couple qui
en plus une image sont restés moderne et
assez réalisme très cruel c'est une idée
qui me plaît beaucoup
en tout cas je le dis tout net vous êtes
l'un et l'autre éblouissant dans ce film
donc drôle d'endroit pour une rencontre
un film qui sort demain très vite parce
qu'avec vous le temps passe vite laurent
cabrol vous dira dans un instant le
temps qu'il fera demain à 23h30 philippe
le fait vous présentera notre tout
dernier journal demain 645 télématin
merci de nous avoir suivis et à demain
20 heures
oh